Mexico says it's overwhelmed that 6 000
migrants a day are crossing here at its
Southern border and looking to push on
to its northern neighbor the United
States
it exceeds whatever capacity we have
even though Mexico wants to do a good
job
for many the first city they reach is
tapachula just a few kilometers from the
Guatemalan border it's full to
overflowing people have been queuing for
days outside a mobile Asylum module for
papers to try and get through the
country
sleeping on the floor it's rained on us
then the sun we sleep in the queue so we
don't lose our place
let's organize buses to it in its words
depressurize tapachula and take people
to be processed in another nearby City
up the route but there are not enough in
our seats
so another camp in the dirt by the
roadside where Maria Stephanie and her
family are waiting
some people have tents we don't we lost
everything after leaving the diary Gap
and so we've been out in the open and if
it rains where are we going to shelter
and with the children too
[Music]
on the northern border the same story
Tijuana Sierra Juarez Matamoros all
migrant cities all full this is just a
small number of the people heading
through tapachula and Mexico right now
where are they from some are from
Venezuela a country where seven million
people have left in recent years fleeing
a ruined economy some are from Haiti
fleeing terrible gang violence and
hunger in that country others are from
Cuba others are from Nicaragua there's
various countries in this region right
now that have political instability or
economic instability and all of them are
hoping to find something better in the
United States meanwhile those at the
heart of this continue their Journey
sleeping rough suffering hunger and
extortion only the dream of safety and
prosperity in the United States keeps
them going John Holman Al Jazeera
tapatula
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera